so let's have a deeper look at CSS
sizing I've given this image a fixed
size 640 by 360 pixels which is the
natural size of the image it looks great
but of course when I resize the window
the image gets cropped and remember the
problem we had earlier on a phone the
image is larger than the viewport which
means that to see the whole image you
have to scroll horizontally
let's try relative sizing I set the
image width to 100% and it looks good in
the smaller browser window and looks
good on the phone but when I resize the
image larger by resizing the browser
window it starts to get pixelated and
blurry let's do something about that if
we set the max width of the image to
100% the image will expand nicely but
only ever as wide as its natural width
to simple things you can learn from this
for devices such as laptops and desktop
monitors don't assume the window size is
the same as the screen size and don't
assume the window size will always stay
the same using max width can be a good
way to respond gracefully to a change to
a larger viewport when you're thinking
responsively consider large displays as
well as small so what if you want two
images to fit side-by-side no matter the
size of the viewport well that's easy
just use relative sizing 50% width but
what if you want to add a 10 pixel
margin between the images you can just
add margin right 10 pixels right you can
get around this with our old friend calc
calc allows you to do simple
calculations and CSS values and that's a
great way to combine absolute and
relative values for example combining a
percentage width with a fixed margin now
the calculation here looks a little
complex but all we're saying is to give
each image 1/2 of the width available
I've also used the last of type selector
to ensure there's only am
between the images and none to the right
of the second image